la seule centrale de france pour les
femmes est à rennes là arrivent toutes
celles qui ont à purger des peines
importantes qui peuvent aller jusqu'à la
perpétuité
comment vivent ces femmes qui n'ont que
24 heures par an pour voir leurs enfants
leurs familles leurs amis qui sont elles
et que pense-t-elle du sort qui leur est
fait qu'il aurait réservé sur les trente
et une sur les 31 mille prisonniers en
france il y à 1000 prisonnière et pour
la première fois depuis cinq ans une
équipe de tf1 a eu l'autorisation de les
rencontrer ces femmes c'est un document
que vous propose une vieille elles sont
230 à la centrale de rennes
moyenne d'âge 36 ans elles ont tué volé
battu des enfants fait du trafic de
drogue
la punition des années de détention
tout désormais se passe pour elle entre
les murs de la prison
chaque jour les détenus travaillent dans
les ateliers gagne de l'argent ce qui
permet de payer une part de ce qu'elle
coûte à la société
en arrivant à la centrale venant des
maisons d'arrêt elle passe deux ou trois
mois dans ce centre d'accueil
ce n'est qu'ensuite qu'elle découvre la
cellule dans laquelle désormais elles
vont vivre
je reconnais que pour les jeunes c'est
très cul mais qu'on est là et qu'on
mangeait de s'habituer à la craie soir
la dame on s'habitue qu'en volant sera
même ceux on est obligé soi même vous
comprenez moi je vole au dessus des murs
mais c'est pas tout le monde qui peut le
faire vous compreniez depuis combien de
temps ça fait trois ans que je suis en
prison et vous êtes là encore coco midon
encore 11 en jeu près 14 ans pour quelle
raison ou non
pour meurtre vous trouvez que le
tribunal était celle est réglé et je
trouvais pourquoi ils ont pas tellement
fait attention aux circonstances que
pour l'enfance et d'une que ça s'est
fait sous sol ivresse donc je ne voulais
pas faire cette chose là pour qu'il a
été votre enfance
dire que bombay et hantise j'ai été
placé en nourrice
mes parents m'ont repris à l'âge de 16
ans et avec mon père avait une entente
tellement formidable avec dans leur
dernière année de détention s'il n'y a
pas eu de problème elles peuvent
bénéficier d'une semi-liberté
elle travaille alors à l'extérieur et
rentre le soir à la prison
c'est le cas de dominique lain souffert
moralement je n'ai pas trouver de
compagnes vraiment très très près de
moins me sourira solitude complète
bon vous sortez dans cinq jours oui
quelle est la première chose que vous
allez faire mais assez de téléphoner
chez moi entendre la voix de mon fils et
je vais m'occuper de mon travail
immédiatement
le constructeur travaille physiquement
ça a été très difficile
et là j'ai vraiment c'est un coup de
chance que j'ai d'avoir un travail
c'est exactement ce que désiraient
qu'est ce que parce que vous pensez que
la prison vous apporter quelque chose
beaucoup de réflexions sur moi-même et
sur les autres
il y à un sujet particulièrement délicat
à aborder dans une prison celui de la
sexualité c'est par l'acte physique en
lui même qui pose question je pense que
les problèmes sont plutôt de domaine
affectif et la souffrance et vient du
manque d'avoir de vivre dans un univers
féminin
la souffrance est plutôt au niveau du
manque de le contacter de caresses
d'attention de bon il faut il faut être
heureux il faut être regardées pour
aimer sablier pour aimer être belle pour
et mais bon c'est c'est plutôt à ce
niveau il est certain qu'il ya des
femmes qui ont peut-être des problèmes
purement physique mais je pense qu'il ya
une certaine pudeur autour de ce genre
de problème et puis elles ont quand même
oui je pense que la pudeur de la réserve
mais je ne pense pas qu'il vient une
vraie souffrance purement physique quand
même ici très peu de révolte
quelques disputes un seul suicide en dix
ans mais surtout des actes
d'automutilation je pense qu'elles ont
un besoin d'avoir contre elle c'est
surtout beaux moments de cafard et dont
le droit pour vienne
leur parler un petit peu alors est ce qu
poète et qu'on passe un quart d'heure a
fait ça rentre dans l'ordre
ces femmes vivent 5 10 15 ans ou plus
seul dans une cellule
le jour de la sortie elle préfère ne pas
trop y penser car après la passivité de
la vie carcérale vient l'angoissent de
la liberté oublier c'est possible de se
réinsérer jeunes eux ce n'est pas facile
ce n'est pas facile pour plusieurs
raisons qui tiennent fait que la
personne a été écarté de la société
pendant un certain temps plus ou moins
long mais surtout qui tiennent aussi à
ce qu'elle va retrouver à l'extérieur ce
qu'elle va retrouver n'est pas forcément
ne laquelle n'est pas forcément très
accueillants et d'autre part un a
personne qui sort de prison peut se
retrouver avec les face aux problèmes
qu'ils ont à me raison
demain elles auront payé le prix de leur
liberté serons-nous prêts à les accepter